Ben glebe five-year tenure plan
interesting five-year plan idiot test is
completing season seven or eight we do a
couple of years sometimes or nine it
would be great if Sinha dopes was doing
also season five or six if I at five
years from now which can be watched by
the way at youtube.com slash total
anarchy TV Sinha dopes a great comedy
about it movie theater sells weed you
should watch it and just doing other
things I'd like to have some more movies
under my belt some live action acting
roles and I'd like to in the next couple
of years I have another show on the air
that I on TV that I've that I've sold i
created i'm a host or actor of in that i
created that really is more my creative
vision I'm I'd like to do all that
together plus bigger stand-up dates
touring theaters I'm always touring but
bigger venues would be great and the
ability to take a little bit of time off
and that if it's possible and it is not
type of you can find some time off and a
flourish and it may be a family oh okay
family well I don't think about that a
lot but possibly right next five years
I'm going to do it that's at least be
part of the next 10-year plan most
likely and then 10 year plan would be
just you know having just my career
being a way that I'm entertaining as
many people as possible that i'm
reaching a broader audience i don't have
to struggle anymore to get people in the
seats or get eyeballs on the screen to
people are enough trusting and what I
put out there that they just will be
very interested in seeing what I put out
there so that i don't feel like i'm
wasting energy of things i like to do
sometimes I love to entertain even just
five people and I always do and I give a
show in front of two people the same
amount of energy that I give to a show
in front of 12,000 people but it just
feels better to do it in front of more
people because you feel like he's made
that many more people happy that day
so just bigger scale of what's going on
now I have very happy in my life but
would be fun to just be able to do
things on a grander scale
you